i'm still trying to figure out who i
am i'm not sure yet
but i'm trying to find the answer
there's so many layers to aretha
franklin she's an artist
she's a woman she's an icon
but the biggest impact on her were the
people in her life
when your star there's a certain
expectation of excellence
everyone wants you ms franklin and so a
big part of aretha's journey and the
film is how
she negotiates professional and personal
relationships with people that she loves
your specialty she was an extraordinary
talent they want to hear you sing
surrounded by extraordinary talents and
so this film needed a true ensemble cast
there's forest twitter cart who plays
ciel franklin
aretha's father audra mcdonald is her
mother and
little skye who plays a young aretha and
mary j
blood is dead in washington and marlon
williams
was her husband ted i'd like to take you
out i like you to take me up
aretha franklin's journey is inspiring
because trying to find your
individuality
is the hardest thing in the world to do
we want original songs made for aretha
only so it's just special movie about a
special woman and i just feel so blessed
to be a part of this
you're not about to mess this up for me
aretha was able to
express very profound emotional things
because of the struggles
she was going through singing is sacred
when she sang there was something that
was so fundamentally connected
to the human spirit you were moved
aretha is a queen of soul i heard songs
they're just so
inspirational what's most important is
that you are treated with
dignity and respect you out here but i
can see you still that little girl in
your daddy's living room
when i was a little girl i heard a lot
of aretha in my home
and i was always moved by her voice and
how it gave me chills what do you want
to say
i esp find out what it means to me
i remember you see take care
to get to the joy is to show the
struggle
and the only way for the audience to
understand how extraordinary she is
is to show what she overcame i need a
change
i want to sing what i want to sing she
experienced so
much and all of us wanted to pay tribute
to aretha franklin
[Music]
you